BRADY HARAN: Some of you may
have seen an earlier video on
Numberphile, where I asked a
bunch of YouTubers to tell me
their favorite number.
It was people like Vsource,
Veritasium, Vihart, both the
Vlog Brothers, and a few people
who didn't start with a
V.
CGPGREY: I'm CGPGrey.
HENRY REICH: My name's Henry.
I make MinutePhysics videos.
DESTIN: I'm Destin.
My number is 21.
STEVE SPANGLER: And to a
magician, the number 13 is the
best number in the
whole world.
BRADY HARAN: But then I asked
all of you guys to tell me
your favorite numbers and put
them in the comments section
under the video.
And loads of you did.
So now what we've done is gone
through loads of those
comments and found out a few
things about YouTube's
favorite number.
I know it's not actually
YouTube's favorite number.
But you know what I mean.
First of all, I've got to say,
all the hard work's been done
by a guy from Colorado
called Dave Wiley.
So huge thanks to him.
And all the data and graphs and
things I'm about to show
you can be found on my blog.
And I'll have a link
under the video.
Now, Dave spent many long hours
using a combination of
clever programming and hard
work to harvest 6,041
comments, and extract
5,286 numbers.
So what was your favorite
number?
Well, you're not going to be
surprised to hear what the
most commonly chosen
number was.
Are you ready?
It was 7.
Not far behind was 3.
Then we had 42, courtesy
of Douglas Adams.
8.
And then 13.
Here's a bigger list,
with the top 25.
There are those ones
I just mentioned.
And as I said before, you
can see more detail
about this on the blog.
Now, it would only take one
person choosing Graham's
number to really wreak havoc
with some forms of averages.
And, well, 31 of you chose
Graham's number.
But the median value was 16,
meaning an equal number of
people chose numbers
below and above 16.
Odd numbers proved slightly more
popular than even ones.
And I find this one
interesting.
4,617 of you chose integers, and
266 chose transcendental
numbers, like pi and e.
And speaking of pi, it was the
most popular choice among the
constants and named numbers.
152 votes for pi.
Next was the golden ratio;
e; pi's nemesis, tau; and
Graham's number.
You can also see imaginary
numbers.
And infinity, if you
want to call that a
number, also on the list.
But I think j's punching
slightly above its weight,
because of the advocacy of
Henry from MinutePhysics.
If you watch the original
video, you'll know
what that's all about.
HENRY REICH: Who wants to pick
the team that's going to win
all the time?
Who wants to pick the
New York Yankees?
You want to pick the underdog.
You don't want to pick what
everyone else has
already gone for.
BRADY HARAN: A lot of you chose
numbers relating to birthdays.
Popular culture played a big
role, perhaps unsurprisingly.
Now, if you want to look at
those graphs, see more stats,
get more into all of this, go
and have a look at my blog.
The link is underneath.
And a special thanks to Dave,
who did all the hard work in
getting all that information
from the comments.
And as I said, we didn't
use all the comments.
We had to draw a cutoff line at
some point, so Dave could
start working.
People are still adding comments
and favorite numbers
to the list now.
So there are plenty
more Numberphiles
to have a look at.
I think this is our 112th.
And if you've watched all of
them, why not check out some
of my other channels,
about chemistry, and
physics, and astronomy?
Information in the video
description.
Cheers.